euh ellisabeth levvi est avec nous
l'antisémitisme qui pose un problème de
vie aux Juifs vient en général de
musulmans êtes-vous choqué par les
propos d'Élisabeth levvi on va voir déjà
le sondage et il va continuer on pouvez
continuer à réagir bien sûr chez vous
voyez 62 % sont d'accord avec Elizabeth
Levi oui 37 % donc oui oui sont oui ne
sont pas choqués et non ne sont pas
choqués à 67 % vous n'êtes pas choqué
vous Daniel non je suis pas choquée
parce que ellisabeth Levi on sait elle
est quand même un peu dans l'outrance
mais c'est bien de provoquer un choc
puisque c'est c'est la plupart des gens
sont quand même très choqués par cette
phrase parce qu'il faut voir la vérité
en face il faut arrêter de de se leurer
on a passé la semaine à parler de
l'antisémitisme de Jean-Marie Le Pen des
années 90 excusez-moi l'antisémitisme il
y a des formes différentes aujourd'hui
il y a évidemment de l'extrême droite il
y a de l'extrême gauche il y a
l'islamisme et et là on s'est voilé la
face pendant une semaine avant cette
manifestation qui était très importante
hier et moi excusez-moi je n'ai pas vu
beaucoup de musulmans hier
l'imamig chagou pardon al a reçu des
menaces par qu'il a appelé excusez-moi
j'arrive pas reçu des menaces par qu'il
a appelé ses frères musulmans à défilé
donc je pense qu'il y a un problème et
quelqu'un comme Elisabeth Levy elle peut
choquer je le comprends tout à fait mais
elle pose de vraies questions et elle
regarde les choses en face permettez-moi
de vous poser une question où est
l'outrance si je dis la vérité en quoi
la vérité ce que je veux dire perzmo
juste de vous dire vous mais je
comprends pas pourquoi c'est outrancier
je viens de donner des faits je ne suis
pas ravi de ces faits j'ai grandi moiême
épiné sur scène quand ça ne se passait
pas comme ça donc je je donne des faits
qui c'est depuis 2000 de nombreux
chercheurs de nombreuses institutions
ont observé la montée de cet
antisémitisme musulman de nombreux
professeurs et je suis sidéré qu'au lieu
de discuter éventuellement de la raison
de ces faits au lieu de discuter de
comment combattre cela comment mobiliser
tous ces musulmans qui eux ne partagent
pas ses idées antisémites au lieu de
disc de
ça pour savoir si Elizabeth lville etire
essaye de gagner de l'argent parce que
c'est toujours ce que dit Gilles verd me
l'a fait à chaque fois ou si ellisabeth
lé est tout transancière je dis la
vérité pour l'instant a des fait que
j'ai cité des études l'Institut
Montaigne le CNRS tous ces l'OP tous ces
instituts observent la même chose donc
et puis écoutez parler à n'importe le
prof qui enseigne en banlieu je ve dire
il va vous expliquer ce comment les
Juifs sont traités comment ils sont vus
si vous voulez par leurs petits élèves
musulmans par beaucoup de leurs petits
élèves musulmans pas je je suis blessé
je vais essayer de rester calme euh à
mon avis ça va pas durer longtemps non
non non vous avez prononcé une phrase
qui est horrible je vais vous la citer
c'est il y a d'excellents français parmi
les musulmans vous avez dit textosa je
vais remplacer musulmans par juifs ou
catholique il y a d'excellents français
parmi les Juifs il y a d'excellents
français parmi les catholiques ça
provoque un séisme dans la rue parce que
c'est stigmatisé la majeure partie
l'écrasante partie
99,99 % des musulmans qui sont des
Français exemplaires qui s'intègr
parfaitement et vous leur tapez dessus à
longueur de temps et ce que vous avez
dit c'est que vous avez mêlé musulmans à
Hamas à terroristes pour vous les
musulmans c'est le Hamas et ce sont les
terroristes qui frappent mais vous avez
dit ça qui frappent sur sol français
mais nous mais
nousise
Biss laissez-moi finir les terroristes
les terroristes ce ne sont pas des
musulmans il dévoient l'islam les
terroristes français qui frappent sur le
sol français ou les terroristes
étrangers qui frappent prétendument au
nom de l'islam ils dévoie l'islam donc
ce que vous faites c'est stigmatiser 6
millions de personnes en leur crachant
dessus et vous crachez votre haine d'une
manière qui est ignominieuse il y en a r
c'est insupportable votre festival de
gros mots aussi commence à bien faire je
vous parle depuis tout à l'heure
gilberdez depuis tout à l'heure je
constate surtout que vous êtes infichu
de
répondre vous êtes affichu de répondre à
quoi que ce soit au fait que j'ai énoncé
je vous ai dit qu'il avta le c'était les
terroristes c'est ça que vous avez dit
soit vous me laissez répondre soit c'est
pas la peine donc 1 je vous ai cité
d'accord des musulmans car tous les
musulmans ne sont pas Islam mais tous
les islamistes sont musulmans oui mais
mus on est français on est
français
pardonnezmexiste très bien alors allez-y
paramour vous
voyezez-moi vous voyez quoi quand vous
regardez vous voyez un bououle vous
voyez un arabe vous voyez un
terroristeul niveau
d'argumentation je suis obligé de
discuter
AEL ans madame non mais
franchementement
honte regardez-moi pas alors allez-y
alors vous voyez quoi en regardant
madame un islamiste un tueur mais non
c'est pas possible d'accepter ça onut
pas ENIT incroyable comme vous êtes
incapable de regarder la vérité en face
je regarde tous les jours en face madame
la vérité c'est votre vérité madame
votre vérité je préfère baisser les yeux
vous
regardezth bon alors premièrement je
vous ai dit que au niveau planétaire
d'accord il y a un contentieux assez
anci ancien et que il y a dans beaucoup
de pays arabau musulmans et et beaucoup
de pays musulmans non arabes d'ailleurs
un antisémitisme frénétique d'accord
deuxièmement je vous ai cité par
ailleurs des gens dans nos banlieux qui
quand ils manifestaient pour Gaza en
2014 criait en même temps mort aux Juifs
ça ça ne vous ensuite je vous ai cité un
sondage je vous ai cité des professs sœ
je vous ai cité des juifs qui ont quitté
la mais vous à part m'insulter
franchement et à trafiquer ce que je dis
vous êtes incapable de répondre je n'ai
pas encore entendu une seule réponse que
pouvez-vous me dire des enfants juifs
qui ont quitter l'école publique en scè
saint qu'avez-vous à leur dire à cela
alors Jacques card voulez réagir moi je
je je voudrais répondre simplement à la
question que vous posez non je ne suis
pas choqué parce que je considère que ce
sont des questions que la société doit
se poser société elle doit se poser ses
questions en essayant d'y répondre pas
en répondant à côté parce que là toutes
les réponses que vous faites c'est une
réponse sur l'histoire c'est une réponse
sur l'amour une réponse sur l'amalgame
mais vous répondez jamais à la question
en fait c'est une question à laquelle
sur laquelle travaillent des chercheurs
des des journalistes ont enquêté sur ces
territoires perdus de la République
évidemment attendez je vais essayer de
terminer mon argumentaire parce que ça
fait un moment que j'attends donc s'il
vous plaît essayez de ne pas me couper
la parole ce qu'elle dit c'est pas que
ce sont les musulmans dans leur ensemble
qui pose un problème ell disent certains
d'entre eux c'est à chaque fois le
fondamentalisme religieux l'application
de la charia et la traduction de cette
application de la charia sous sa forme
la plus violente qui est à l'origine des
attentats vous ne pouvez pas le
contester ça donc cette action
terroriste elle
existe systématiquement dans l'amalgame
sy vous répondez pas à la
questionz pas à la question moi je
voudrais vous raconter quelque chose
j'ai vécu aux États-Unis j'ai vu une
famille de 20 oui ben voilà très bien
j'ai j'ai fait reportage sur une famille
française de confession juives qui est
partie à la suite des attentats et qui
m'a raconté à la suite de ce qui s'est
passé de Mohamed mer de ce qui s'est
passé à Toulouse et qui a émigré
uniquement pour ça et qui qui qui
m'expliquait qu'elle ne pouvait pas
exprimer sa judéité qu'elle ne pouvait
pas s'exprimer et que à chaque fois
c'était ça qui lui posait problème et
que c'était devenu impossible de vivre
en France c'est quelque chose que vous
ne pouvez
pas moi je m'attache à un mot que
dit mais moi où j'habite il n'y a pas
ces problèmes là c'est vrai qu'il y a
des problèmes quelque fois qui a eu des
problèmes d'antisémitisme il y a eu des
problèmes où il
y la France vous prenez un cas à ville
un en mais y a pas que vous insultez
tout la moi j'ai des amis
juifs monsieur pas à des questions
d'amour d'histoire ou d'AM ça n'est pas
le problème il
faut mais excusez-moi il y ce débat là
il faut l'avoir et il faut l'avoir
calmement évidemment que la réponse elle
est pas aussi simple que uniquement les
musulm l'antisémitisme il vient
effectivement de de plein d'autres
formes on a parlé on aç oui 150 ans il
s'exprime parfois à gauche il s'exprime
parfois au il vient parfois de l'extrême
droite il s'exprime sous plein de formes
mais vous ne pouvez pas contester le
fait que il peut aussi s'exprimer d'une
de la part de musulmans qui qui de
certains mus de certains musulmans c'est
une question qui est posé et on doit
pouvoir y répondreiment voilà sans faire
d'amalgame je peux ajouter juste une
chose moi je suis un peu désespéré je
suis un peu désespéré parce que je suis
un peu désespéré parce que euh
j'espérais en réalité dans cette crise
depuis le 7 octobre j'espérais que
beaucoup de musulmans se joindraient à
nous dans le combat contre l'antisémitin
ou qu'il soit et je vais vous dire ce
qui me désespère encore plus c'est que
je viens en face de vous avec des
données que vous connaissez vous les
connaissez vous savez qu'à Drancy les
dernières familles juives ont dû partir
vous savez que des familles juives ont
vu leur domicile taguer je ne vous parle
même pas de maintenant je vous parle de
il y a plusieurs années vous savez quand
je le répète en scène sainten un
inspecteur d'académie l' reconnu je veux
dire dans les écoles l'antisémitisme bat
son plein et au lieu de m'aider à le
résoudre qu'est-ce vous êtes dans le
pire dans la pire des raction le déni le
déni ça veut dire que vous vous empichez
vous vous empichez
de votre rve il n'existe pas Madame l
votre rêve il va pas exister ce que vous
dites là c'est un rêve parce que vous
parlez depuis tout à l'heure alors moi
je vais paser Mohamed mer je vais pasier
ça existait qu'il a couru derrière des
enfants juifs pour leur tirer dessus je
vais pas le nier en même temps le
nazisme c'était pas des musulmans et
pourtant il est parti de là de la guerre
moi je suis pas cultivé mais le nazisme
c'était pas des musulmans et vous pouvez
pas arriver là et dire j'ai été en
Israël j'ai vu des bébés SAU ce qu'on
condamne évidemment qu'il s'est passé
des choses en Israël sans jamais dire à
côté il se passe aussi des choses à Gaza
vous ne parlez jamais de Gaza vous ne
parlez pas des hôpitaux qui ont plus
d'électricité en ce moment vous ne
parlez pas des bombardements ça ne
pourra jamais exister votre paix moi ici
j'ai dit je ne veux pas qu'il a de camp
et moi j'ai triste ce weekend parce que
ce weekend ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'il y a des gens comme vous qui disent
c'est les musulmans al je dis pas que ça
existe pas mais vous musul pas AR en
disant la S la la moi j'entends pas tous
les jours un un un enfant juif ou un
adolescent juif ou un adulte juif qui
s'est fait tuer par un musulman je
l'entends pas mais je ni pas attendez
attendez je n pas qu'il analimi n'existe
pas je le ni pas je sais que ça existe
je sais qui qui a fait des des atrocités
àanalimi mais je sais aussi dire
regardez aussi à Gaza il se passe des
trucs en ce moment c'est l'UNICEF c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui demande la fin des
bombardements vous avez é en Israël vous
dites j'é Israël vous avez Gaza
jamais c'est vous énervez pas mais c'est
ça votre
problème je par 2014 je vous parle de
2000 moi je vous parle de
202 pas gaz de vous permettez si je
croyais que le sujet c'était
l'antisémitisme en
France les musulans les musulmans c'est
le sujet pale
btis très bien alors je vais vous
répondre d'abord je vais vous dire une
chose premièrement si vous lisiez mes
article et si vous écoutez mes
chroniques et bien ben vous n'avez pas
le temps vous sauriez que j'ai déjà
parlé évidemment des civils qui meurent
à gaz ce soir c'est ça le
problèmez je
pour je commence à vous répondre vous me
recoupez la parole alors qu vous me
laisserez parler je parlerai d'accord ce
soir il est déjà assez compliqué de
parler alors je suis tout à fait
d'accord qui parle plus oui et en plus
vous crier bon très bien j'arrête
alors vous voulez pas que je parle
allez-y
allez-y ça va se calmer allez-y si le
sujet c'est det triste pour tous les
cibil de Gaza je le suis on parle pour
l'instant de haine des Juifs c'était ça
le sujet d'accord donc je suis
absolument triste pour les enfant de
Gaza je souhaite vivement que le RAM
arrête de les tenir en otage et j'espère
que vous le souhaitez également car
c'est le ramasse qui aujourd'hui a mis
son quartier général sous l'hôpital
Chifa que je sache d'accord et qui ont
fait un objectif militaire et c'est
terrible c'est une
tragédie quand vous me dites je ne vous
parle pas simplement des juifs tués vous
avez l'air de prendre ça avec beaucoup
de mépris d'accord pourquoi je vous
parle de la
scène non pourquoi je ce que je vais
dire pourquoi je vous parle de la scène
sint parce que sur la scène sint il y a
eu quatre livres il y a eu Dav l'homme
de journalistes du Monde d' journal
n'est pas particulièrement islamophobe
il y a eu Gill kpel qui n'est pas
particulièrement islamophobe il y a eu
le le alors ça c'était pas la scène
saint c'était encore cétait trappe qui
est à peu près le même genre d'accord et
bien tous ces tous ces tous ces livres
toutes ces études montrent la même chose
et pourquoi la scène Saint- parce que
c'est un département si vous voulez qui
peut en gros constituer une sorte où il
y a beaucoup de musulmans eux-mêmes le
disent c'est une population qui il a pas
que des musulmans c s madame bon
d'accord donc les Juifs ont quitter C
des bhist comme chacun comm
chesson
peécole ça pass bienabeth viment
moiéta plus Mo d' ex d'accord et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pardon c'est pas
que vous soyez si vieux ch C mais
aujourd'hui moi mon père il exerce en sa
ça se passe très bien aussi et vraiment
je vous
dis vous y allez en sa aujourd'hu mon
père est en mort en juin j'y vais moins
mais jusqu'en juin j'y allais tout le
temps est-ce il vous arrivver quelque
chose mais je vais mais c'est marrant
vous savez ce qui s'est passé mon père
était à épiné sur scène il y a
énormément de juifs qui ont quitté des
tas de villes de SC sa où ils étaient
très minoritaires pour se regrouper il y
en a d'autres qui ont quitté la SA saint
pour l'Ouest parisien
pourquoi par dans terit islamis ils ne
sont pas dans les territoires perdus ils
ne sont pas en sécurité mais ce qui est
incroyable si vous voulez ce qui est
incroyable c'est que vous en soyez
encore à nier la réalité qui est
documentée non vous m'avez parlé des
morts je ne vous parle pas que des morts
je vous parle des agressions je vous
parle des
insultes la France madame une insulte
pour les élèves de mon ami qui on va
voir on on on va vir regarde on va voir
le sondage voilà donc êtes-vous choqué
oui à 37 % non à 62 % voilà qui qui
voulait dire un dernier mot je vouis
parler pour Jacques et Madame Levy je
pense que vous êtes pas des gens de
terrain tout simplement que la la
communauté juif attends attends
excuse-moi dire mais on m'a déjà dit
attends' déjà dit tu as fait deux
reportages dans ta vie mais non non mais
moi j'ai pas dit que tu en as fait deux
vous êtes pas les gens de terrain je je
pense que tu veux tu veux qu'on fasse ça
tu veux vraiment qu'on fasse un concours
comme ça terrain moi je t'ai jamais vu
en
BE concours ne me provoque pas je suis
pas en train de te provquer si parce que
tu me dis tu pas quelqu'un de
terin parce que justement je t'ai jamais
vu en B dans dans les
que quand j'écoute madame LV quand
j'écoute madame Li je pense que la FR 30
ans de reportage dire tu peux pas me
dire ça tu les fais pas les 30 ans bravo
t'aiit j'ai fait 30 an de reportage vois
il y a un truc qui s'appelle le
conducteur chaque année il y a les mes
qui mettent les nom est celui qui a fait
plus année après année j'étais dans le
topis tu peux pas dire pasé sur le
voyezvous dans la semaine et vous
parz
je jeis TR de dire Mame pardonnez-moi
j'ai un beau père qui s'appelle David
donc je sais de quoi je
parle je pense que la la communauté les
Français de confession juif en vous
entendant en vous écoutant pardonnez-moi
il sont en train de se retourner vos
ancêtres se retournent quand on quand
vous entend parler vous ê pas une
personne pour moi qui représente le prix
Nobel de la paix ce que vous avez dit
actuellement vous avez choqué des
parents vous avez choqué des enfants et
des adultes je ne pense pas que vous
soyez le côté connecteur entre les
Françaises de confessions musulmanes les
5 millions est- que la vérité vous
intéresse bien sûr madame bien sûr parce
que moi je me sensé parce
que ici même ici même sur ce plateau
j'ai condamné le Hamas donc vous
inquiétez pas donc pour le coup je suis
en train de me dire et puis
effectivement je pense que vous savez
lire mais que vous lisez très peu et
encore moins sur la religion musulmane
et encore une
fois merci vas-y vas-y vas-y discours il
va falloir vous savez quoi trouver des
discours trouver des
mots REM REM REM les
personnes vous AZ raison on rassemblera
pas pi la vérité on les rassemblera pas
enant la
vérit j'ai oui mais c'est le nom quite
vérité jeis vous laisser Lect merciabeth
Jordan vient nous rejoindre dans un
instant pour parler toute
l'actualité lui poser toutes vos
questions merci appelez-vous dans la
semaine à tout de suite pe beuté à tout
de suite
merci